the Trump organization just got nuked
from orbit it's not getting a lot of
press but this is a blockbuster ruling
that just put Trump's entire business
Empire in Jeopardy and it's just going
to get worse for him and this likely
isn't just some slap on the wrist that
he can get out of no this looks like
it's really going to her Trump in the
place that he really cares about his
pocketbook now New York judge Arthur
engeron has ruled that Trump committed
financial fraud by overstating the value
of his assets the judge canceled the New
York business certificates of all 131
companies related to Trump and his sons
in New York stripping the ability of the
Trump family to do business in that
state and at the time of this video the
Trump group is currently in trial over
the other fraud allegations it's being
presided by none other than the same
judge Enron and it's not going well uh
it's a bench trial because apparently
Trump's lawyer Alina habba forgot to
check the box to request a jury trial
she really earned that ft ranking but
even before trial the judge's order on
the first count is catastrophic and the
repercussions from this are staggering
this is like bankruptcy but much worse
and as you may know the New York
attorney general filed charges alleging
that the Trump organization committed
fraud for at least a decade involving
conduct across more than 23 different
properties and other assets we did a
video on this complaint which you can
watch for a deep dive into those
allegations but here's a quick recap
when valuing the Trump properties the
Trump organization would change
methodology on how to Value the
properties from year to year or even
within the same year depending on who
they were talking to some of the fraud
was allegedly accomplished through
sophisticated accounts and slide of hand
but other acts were blatant and easy to
detect for example Trump estimated that
his own Triplex apartment in Trump Tower
was 30,000 ft when it was actually
10,996 ft in 2015 Trump valued the
apartment at $327 million in total or $
29,7 38 per square foot that price was
absurd since at that point only one
apartment in New York City had ever been
sold for more than $100 million and that
sale was in a newly built Ultra tall
tower no apartment in the the
30-year-old Trump Tower has ever sold
for more than 16.5 million and he
allegedly well no I guess at this point
it's not alleged anymore uh the it's
been proven that he used the same trick
with his Florida real estate the
Attorney General said that Trump valued
marago as high as 739 million when it
should have been valued at around one10
that amount or $75 million attorney
general Laticia James said that the
higher valuation was quote based on the
false premise that it was unrestricted
property and could be developed for
residential use even though Mr Trump
himself signed Deeds donating his
residential development rights and
sharply restricting changes to the
property and the judge discussed marago
quite a bit in his detailed order here's
a quick rundown because it shows how
Trump uh G the system and why he's in
big trouble now when uh Palm Beach
County Florida denied Trump the right to
develop the property Trump established a
conservation easement which is basically
a restriction in the deed that says he
won't develop the property that gave him
a tax right off because now he can't
build houses or anything else on that
property however Trump then told lenders
that the property was worth a lot of
money because someone could come along
and development uh which was an obvious
lie it appears that he gave the
conservation easement because there was
nothing that he could do with that
particular land and Trump's various
business entities played these games
with property valuation for decades
Lisha James filed a civil enforcement
action against the companies and
referred the case to Federal prosecutors
in the southern district of New York so
far the feds have declined to indict
Trump on these charges but the New York
attorney general's enforcement action
brought seven causes of action under New
York EX itive law section 6312 this law
authorizes the New York attorney general
to bring civil lawsuits to enjoin
repeated fraudulent or illegal Acts or
persistent fraud or illegality in
carrying on conducting or transacting of
business civil penalties for those who
violate the law include actual damages
disgorgement of profits uh cancelling of
corporate certificates and other
prohibitions we'll come back to that
later now Trump had already tried to get
the lawsuit dismissed at an early stage
by claiming that any discrepancies in
the valuations of his properties are the
fault of his accountants May
but he lost that effort on Appeal on
summary judgment Trump raised all the
same defenses and that made judge
engeron very unhappy the judge wrote the
quote defendants arguments that ogag has
neither capacity nor standing to sue
under executive law 6312 and that the
disclaimers of non-party accountant
mards in slate defendants invoke the
time Loop in the film Groundhog Day this
court emphatically rejected these
arguments and in its preliminary
injunction decision and in its dismissal
decision and the first Department
affirmed both defendant contention that
a different procedural posture mandates
a reconsideration or a foror a reversal
is pure sophistry so here's legal eagle
Pro tip number one when the judge
Compares your argument to the film
Groundhog Day and accuses you of
sophistry you're about to get a legal
Beatdown now the gist of Trump's
argument here was that the New York AG
wasn't really acting in the interest of
consumer protection and this prompted
the judge to call out Trump's lawyers
for adding the word consumer to a legal
decision that does not appear anywhere
in the decision as the judge explained
quote defendants glaringly misrepresent
the requirement of an executive law 6312
cause of action citing to people versus
non-am leasing systems the defendants
assert that ogag must show the practice
as one likely to mislead a reasonable
consumer acting reasonably under the
circumstances however the word consumer
did not appear anywhere in that
reference decision and defendants
characterization of its holding is
inaccurate additionally Trump tried to
argue that the state can't sue him
because the statements of financial
condition that he filed with the state
contain disclaimers from his accountants
that they haven't been audited and
therefore the company can't say whether
the financial statements comply with
generally accepted accounting principles
or Gap the judge rejected this argument
don't believe anything you read some
people call it a worthless Clause
because it makes the statement and
anything you read in the statement
worthless it says go out and do your own
research go out and do your own due
diligence you have to study the
statement carefully do not believe
anything quote those non-party
disclaimers do not insulate the
defendants from liability as they
plainly state that Donald J Trump is
responsible for the preparation in Fair
presid presentation of the financial
statement in accordance with accounting
principles generally accepted in the
United States of America and that's
extremely common the accountants need
that disclaimer because they're relying
on the information that the company
provides them the company can't use that
disclaimer to say that they weren't
responsible for providing accurate
information not surprisingly msar
dropped Trump as a client in 2022 citing
his misleading and probably fraudulent
personal financial statements next the
judge excoriates Trump for repeating
another argument that several courts
have already rejected namely that
discouragement of profits is unavailable
as a matter of of law when the ogag has
not alleged specific Financial losses uh
the judge reminds Trump that an appeals
court has already quote made it clear in
this very case that we have already held
that the failure to allege losses does
not require dismissal of a claim for
disgorgement under executive law 6312
now that's a big one because Trump at
least publicly has been arguing that no
one was harmed by his misrepresentations
the banks got paid back and therefore
there are no damages no Bank was
affected no Bank was hurt they don't
even know why they have to be involved
but this law allows the uh attorney
general to make the Trump organization
disgorge any profit that they made
related to these misrepresentations
during this time period and who knows
that could be a lot of money and
continuing with some truly f-tier
lawyering Trump's attorney cited a case
that has been superseded and overruled
and they also cited the Court's decision
in the Trump University case where quote
the first Department unambiguously
declared that the Attorney General is in
fact authorized to bring a cause of
action for fraud under executive law
6312 now that brings us to legal eagle
prot tip number two drawing attention to
a case that resulted in your client
paying $25 million to settle fraud
claims is rarely a good strategy
especially when your client is going on
trial for more fraud but here's legal
eagle Pro tip number three
misrepresenting the precedent and
repeating arguments that you already
lost puts you on Shaky Ground with
judges and as judge engeron put it quote
in rejecting such Arguments for the
second time this court caution that
sophisticated Council should have known
better however the court declined to
impose sanctions believing it had made
its Point apparently the point was not
received and the court continued quot
defendants conduct in reiterating these
frivolous arguments is egregious we are
Way Beyond the point of sophisticated
Council should have known better we were
at the point of intentional and blatant
disregard of controlling Authority and
law of the case this court emphatically
rejected these arguments as did the
first Department defendant repetition of
them here is indefensible and would you
believe it these lawyers then got
sanctioned for thousands of dollars now
there are two categories of conduct that
can subject a party to liability under
executive law 6312 acts that are
fraudulent and acts that are illegal the
attorney general alleges that the Trump
defendant engaged in both fraudulent and
illegal acts but moved for summary
judgment only as to fraud and there's a
very good reason for this executive law
6312 broadly constru fraud to quote
include acts characterized as dishonest
or misleading and the statute prescribes
any acts committed in the conduct of
business that have the capacity or
tendency to deceive or that create an
atmosphere conducive to fraud such acts
include those committed through any
scheme to defraud and those through
misrepresentation concealment ression or
false pretense and in addition to the
business entities themselves individual
defendants may also be liable for fraud
under Section 6312 if they personally
participated in it or had actual
knowledge of it as when they create an
Enterprise conducive to fraud through
their supervision of the Enterprise and
crucially here the Attorney General does
not have to prove that an intent to
defraud or Reliance this was one of the
Holdings of the lawsuit against Trump
University that broad under Section 6312
may be established without proof of
Center or Reliance and we've talked
about mental States on this channel a
lot some conduct can be illegal or legal
depending on what mental state the
person uh has when they engage in that
conduct and here a lot of these
violations can occur without any
intentionality whatsoever which you know
is bad news when you have proof that the
thing has happened now if your company
ever gets nuked like trumps then you'll
need a good lawyer but if you want a
great lawyer my firm the eagle team can
help if you've had an injury or death in
the family suffered a data breach or are
dealing with Social Security Disability
or workers comp issues we can represent
you or find you the right attorney who
can just click on the link in the
description for free consultation with
my team because you don't just need a
legal team you need the eagle team link
is down below but now back to Trump's
problems and here James has argued that
the statements of financial condition
were false and misleading the Trump
defendant said that they were neither
false nor misleading because quote
there's no such thing as objective value
and there's nothing wrong with adjusting
valuations because of factors such as
the value of the Trump brand as the
court put it quote thus defendants
essenti argue that value is inherently
subjective that because internal brand
valuations are in the eye of the
beholder here Donald Trump they cannot
be overvalued and the Trump defendants
argued that Banks and insurance
companies weren't misled because they
never would have relied on the financial
statements alone as the court put it
quote defendant stances practically
speaking that they may submit false
sfc's as long as the recipients know
from their own due diligence that the
information is false the judge said
accepting this premise would ignore
Decades of settled law that property
valuation is objective not subjective
and that market value is the most
reliable way to establish how much a
property is worth now of course there is
a kernel of Truth in the defendant's
argument that the property valuation
isn't an exact science uh and experts
can certainly disagree and sometimes you
have different valuations for the
purposes of tax basis versus uh Reliance
for uh for collateral but as the judge
explained the problem for Trump is that
these were not small discrepancies quote
what ogag has established in many cases
by clear disputable documentary evidence
is not a matter of rounding errors or
reasonable experts disagreeing OGE has
submitted conclusive evidence that
between 2014 and 20121 defendants
overvalued the assets reported on the
sfc's between
17.27% this amounts to a discrepancy of
between 812 million and $2.2 billion
even in the world of High Finance this
court cannot endorse a proposition that
finds misstatements of at least $812
million to be immaterial defendants have
failed to identify any Authority for the
notion that discrepancy of this
magnitude demonstrated here could be
considered immaterial and that's why the
Attorney General moved for summary
judgment effectively a trial on paper uh
just on one count a standalone violation
of executive law 6312 and to prove that
count the Attorney General only needed
to prove that the financial statements
were false and misleading and that the
defendants repeatedly or persistently
used the statements to transact business
again here there was no intent
requirement and the judge had no problem
finding that the AG proved its case the
judge said that this was a document case
and the documents here clearly contain
fraudulent valuations that defendants
used in business satisfying the oag's
burden to establish liability as a
matter of law against defendants and the
judge slammed Donald Trump's deposition
testimony as well quote the defense
Donald Trump attempts to articulate in
his sworn deposition are wholly without
basis in law or fact he claims that if
the values of the property have gone up
in the years since the sfcs were
submitted that the numbers were not
inflated at the time that is quote but
you take the 2014 statement if something
is much more valuable now or I guess
we'll have to pick a date which was a
little short of now but if something is
much more valuable now then the number
that I have down here is a low number he
also seems to imply that the numbers
cannot be inflated because he could find
a quote buyer from Saudi Arabia to pay
any price He suggests now I know the emo
cases didn't go anywhere but this is
just a truly stunning thing to say when
your international business dealings
were already under scrutiny and you've
received a lot of criticism for
potentially foreign influence it's just
man uh it's kind of like saying well it
was worth it because Vladimir Putin
would have paid me5 billion for this
particular piece of property just it's
feels like the quiet part out loud and
not to mention there is a very famous
incident of trump selling a Florida
property to a Russian oligarch at a
hugely inflated price but I digress uh
judge Enron also touched on the issue of
square footage quote this court takes
judicial notice that the Trump Tower
apartment in which Donald Trump resided
for decades the triplex is
10,996 F feet between 2012 and 2016
Donald Trump submitted sfc's falsely
claiming that the triplex was 30,000 ft
resulting in an overvaluation of between
$114 and $27 million and the court
agreed that quote a discrepancy of this
order of magnitude by a real estate
developer sizing up his own living space
of decades can only be considered fraud
and the judge found that the Attorney
General unquestionably satisfied its
two-prong burden of demonstrating that
the sfc's from 2012 to 2016 calculated
the value of the triplex based on a
false and misleading square footage and
the judge made similar findings with
respect to the Seven Springs estate
Trump Park Avenue 40 Wall Street
Aberdine and several other additional
golf clubs and Mara Lago and the judge
found that Trump overvalued Mara Lago by
an establishing 2300 per. and the judge
was unpersuaded by the testimony of
Lawrence mowen a supposed expert in Palm
Beach property valuation who estimated
the property is worth 1.5 billion when
mowans was asked who would be prepared
to buy the club he said quote I could
dream up anyone from Elon Musk to Bill
Gates and everyone in between Kings
Emperors heads of state anyone with net
worth in the multiple billions I don't
know how many people in the world have a
net worth of more than 10 billion but I
think it's quite a number there are a
lot and in a very pointed footnote the
court said quote obviously this court
cannot consider an expert affidavit that
is based on unexplained and
unsubstantiated dreams so with that we
can finally talk about the Staggering
ramifications uh from this order the
judge ruled that the Attorney General
demonstrated liability on behalf of all
the named individuals defendants on
count one including Trump Donald Trump
Jr Eric Trump Alan weiselberg and Jeff
McCone and as for the entity defendants
parent corporations can only be held
liable for the acts of its subsidiaries
if the parent exercised complete
dominion and control over the subsidiary
and the judge found that quote it is
Undisputed that Donald Trump through one
corporate form or another exercised
complete control over the umbrella of
entities operating in furtherance of or
on behalf of the Trump organization and
the Attorney General established
liability on behalf of all the named
entity defendants when the litigation
started the judge granted the Attorney
General a preliminary injunction and
appointed Barbara Jones as an
independent monitor to ensure that there
is no further fraud or illegal activity
and on August 23rd Jones told the judge
that the defendants had continued to
commit the same acts quote even with a
prelimary injunction in place and with
an independent monitor overseeing their
compliance defendants have continued to
disseminate false and misleading
information while conducting business
and this includes setting up Trump
organization 2 a corporate entity that
defendant established in Delaware back
in October 2022 which looks an awful lot
like an attempt to offload assets before
the case went to trial but with the
corporate monitor in place it's unlikely
that they could have succeeded there
we'll actually see what happens with the
details there but all of this is why the
judge dissolved the business
certificates of 10 Trump business
entities ending their ability to do
business in New York the corporations
are legal fictions and when you take
away and dissolve those companies they
can no longer own property or Shield The
Beneficial owners and the order includes
quote any any other entity controlled or
beneficially owned by the individual
defendants found liable here now the
Trump organization includes about 500
entities and although only 10 were
explicitly included in this order they
own some of Trump's biggest assets
including the property at 40 Wall Street
in Manhattan and the golf course in
Scotland Barbara Jones will continue to
oversee the finances of the Trump
organization pending any further rulings
and obviously Trump is going to appeal
here and the trial is currently
proceeding on the other six counts
falsifying business records conspiracy
to falsify business records filing false
financial statements conspiracy to file
false financial statements insurance
fraud and conspiracy to commit insurance
fraud and by all accounts it's going
very poorly so far expect to follow a
video on that very soon and Leticia
James is seeking at least $250 million
and has asked the court to permanently
bar Trump from serving as an officer
director of any business in New York and
prohibit him from acquiring any real
estate or applying for a loan in the
state for 5 years and the AG wants the
same restrictions for Dawn Jr and Eric
Trump and the ramifications of this
ruling are enormous with lawyers
describing it as the corporate death
penalty the Trump entities are
essentially in a receivership which is a
situation where a receiver or trustee is
appointed to manage the entire company
its assets and all financial and
operating decisions until the companies
are wound down Barbara Jones is in this
role right now and the Trump entities
won't be able to buy or sell anything
without her approval and there'll be a
long process of figuring out which
assets all the Trump companies own and
who their creditors are and if this
order is upheld the Trump organization's
assets will have to be liquidated to pay
off all of the creditors and the fact
that these corporate can no longer own
any property and that means that they
could be put up for auction and sold to
the highest bidder and there are many
potential creditors here all of whom are
going to get paid before Trump does if
there is even a surplus based on the
sales here and that includes banks that
gave Trump loans based on fraudulent
valuations insurance companies
contractors construction workers service
workers uh other vendors and also of
course the government uh who will
probably want their unpaid taxes and any
penalties and disgorgement penalties
that come as a result of this verdict
and there is some suggestion that some
or all of Trump's branding rights might
have been assigned to a corporate entity
and that the entity might be affected by
the dissolutions if true and I haven't
been able to drill down this entirely it
could mean that Trump might lose the
ability to capitalize on his own name
and brand in some situations because
they might be sold off to somebody else
irony can be very ironic sometimes so
yeah this is basically like a bankruptcy
for all of the New York entities uh not
the fun bankruptcy Chapter 11 where
everything gets reorganized and the
company continues but the really nasty
one where everything gets sold off for
parts the Chapter 7 bankruptcy and there
are a lot of creditors including the
government who are going to get paid
before Trump does but there are
limitations to this ruling for example
uh Trump owns property in several other
states and all over the world that will
not be part of this case if they weren't
owned by one of the dissolved entities
but that actually may not be much of a
limitation because a a lot of the real
estate that he owns whether it's in the
United States or across the world is
owned by one of these New York companies
and if that real estate is owned by one
of the dissolved New York companies it's
very likely that that real estate is
going to have to be liquidated and the
thing about buying these assets out of
receivership or bankruptcy is that you
have to have the cash on hand to be able
to buy that property and at this point
Trump might be pretty strapped for cash
we'll see the repercussions here are
staggering and who knows what this is
going to look like now if Trump's name
image and likeness rights are sold off
then he'd really benefit from a company
that can get his personal data taken
down online which you could do with
today's sponsor incog now I don't know
about you but I've seen a huge uptick in
the amount of spam I'm getting and it's
no surprise why every year the number in
scope of data breaches worldwide is
rising and you might not know it but
there are hundreds of data Brokers that
possess and sell your personal
information and their numbers grow every
year I was shocked when I saw literally
hundreds of companies who had my
personal data and these data Brokers
might have a whole Shadow profile on you
including your name your address phone
number shopping habits possibly even
your social security number all up for
the highest bidder and at best this
leads to scam calls and at worst
identity theft and doxing so for example
if you're getting tons of Robo calls to
your cell phone or calls from scammers
like I am like basically every day
there's a good chance it's because your
data is online and sometimes it's
completely legal but totally nefarious
like health insurance companies that
rais your rates because they got access
to your personal health data but that's
where incog comes in incog fights on
your behalf to remove your personal data
from data Brokers and deals with any
objections from their side all you have
to do is create an account and give them
approval to work on your behalf and
incog conducts repeated ongoing removals
because even if the broker removes your
data once they can collect it again
which is just so dumb and in cogy makes
sure that your personal information
stays off the market for good and you
can see when incog does this on your
personal dashboard this is mine it shows
that these sites had data on me that was
rated 10 out of 10 on incog sensitivity
scale those Brokers had data including
my contacts financial data and Health
Data but thank incog tells me when the
removal requests are complete so I can
breathe easy it's terrifying to see
exactly how many Brokers have my data
but it's really fun to watch incog get
them to delete that info one by one so
give incog a try by clicking on the link
below and get 60% off incog when you use
the code legal eagle again to get an
exclusive 60% off discount just click on
the link that's on screen right now or
down in the description and use the code
legal eagle after that click on this
link over here for more legal eagle or
I'll see you in court